Salut les Épicurieuses et les Épicurieux.
Aujourd'hui, je ne suis pas seul,
je suis avec une dame...
La Dame de fer !
Et, c'est une chance car
elle ne devrait plus être là aujourd'hui.
20 ans après sa construction,
elle devait être démontée.
C'est grâce à un coup de génie de
Gustave Eiffel qu'elle est restée debout.
Alors, comment a-t-il fait
pour sauver son chef d'œuvre ?
Je vous raconte tout, mais avant,
on va devoir prendre de la hauteur.
On va grimper tout là-haut !
Nous voilà arrivés au cinquième étage.
Alors, j'ai beaucoup de chance car ce niveau n'est pas accessible au public.
D'ici, la vue sur Paris
est vraiment imprenable.
Nous sommes perchés
à 285 mètres de hauteur.
Le 31 mars 1889, Gustave Eiffel
gravit officiellement les marches
de sa tour pour la première fois.
Du parvis au sommet,
elle compte aujourd'hui 1 665 marches
mais à l'époque,
il y en avait 2 000.
Entouré de plusieurs officiels,
il déploie alors le drapeau français.
L'événement est salué
par 21 coups de canon.
La tour Eiffel fait la une des gazettes
dans le monde entier.
Pour le génial entrepreneur, c'est l'aboutissement d'un projet hors normes
qui a germé dans son esprit
5 ans auparavant, en 1884.
Cette année-là, la France prépare
l'exposition universelle de 1889.
Le pays veut en profiter pour célébrer
le centenaire de la Révolution de 1789.
Mais encore faut-il trouver quelque chose
qui marque les esprits.
Nous sommes en pleine révolution
industrielle,
l'objectif des pouvoirs publics
est donc de faire rayonner le génie
industriel français en érigeant une tour gigantesque sur le Champ de Mars.
Comme on aime déjà les chiffres ronds,
on rêve d'une tour de 1 000 pieds, 300 mètres.
À cette époque, Gustave Eiffel
s'est déjà fait un nom dans le domaine des
constructions métalliques
avec 2 ouvrages révolutionnaires :
le pont de Garabit dans le Midi
et l'armature de la statue de la Liberté.
Du solide !
À surface égale,
le fer puddlé, qu’il utilise, est 10 fois
plus résistant que la pierre.
Aussitôt,
ses ingénieurs se mettent au travail.
Deux d'entre eux, Émile Nouguier et Maurice Koechlin, imaginent
un gigantesque
pylône métallique sur 4 pieds
d'exactement 300 mètres de hauteur.
Ce premier croquis n'est pas très élégant,
aussi Stephen Sauvestre,
l'architecte attitré de l'entreprise,
le redessine entièrement.
Cette fois,
le nouveau projet retravaillé et décoré,
séduit Eiffel, qui donne son feu vert
pour que les plans soient présentés.
Le concours est lancé en 1886
et quelques semaines plus tard,
sur la centaine de projets en compétition,
c'est le sien qui est retenu.
Ensuite, tout va très vite,
la Tour est construite en un peu plus
de 2 ans.
Pour réaliser cet exploit,
toutes les pièces sont prémontées dans les ateliers Eiffel
à Levallois-Perret, en proche banlieue.
7 300 tonnes de fer, 18 000 pièces
et 312 mètres plus haut,
la Dame de fer est inaugurée
en grande pompe.
Elle devient le monument
le plus haut du monde.
Son succès est immédiat :
2 millions de personnes, soit 12 000
visiteurs par jour, se pressent au sommet
pour découvrir une vue inédite sur Paris
pendant l'exposition universelle.
Alors, Gustave Eiffel devrait sauter de joie.
Eh bien non, car le contrat qu'il a signé
avec la ville de Paris
prévoit que la Tour doit être démontée
au bout de 20 ans.
Or, lui veut que sa tour reste debout.
Et, pour convaincre
la municipalité de son utilité,
il a une idée :
en faire un laboratoire scientifique.
Avec sa taille exceptionnelle,
c'est l'endroit idéal.
L'idée a germé dans son esprit
bien avant le début des travaux.
Observez la frise qui court autour
du premier étage.
Au moment de la construction,
Eiffel a pris soin d'y faire inscrire
les noms de 72 savants
en lettres capitales.
Y figurent le chimiste Lavoisier,
Daguerre, l'inventeur de la photographie,
ou encore le médecin Xavier Bichat.
Pour être au plus près des travaux
qui vont s'y dérouler,
l'entrepreneur
doit installer ses bureaux sur place.
Il se fait donc construire
un petit appartement,
ici, au quatrième étage.
On va aller y faire un tour.
Bonjour messieurs dames.
Ce n'est pas très grand, hein.
À l'époque, c'était beaucoup plus spacieux,
il n'y avait pas autant
de locaux techniques.
Il y avait des canapés
pour accueillir les visiteurs, un lavabo
et même des toilettes.
Cet appareil,
un phonographe, est également d'origine.
La scène représente Gustave Eiffel,
sa fille Claire
et Thomas Edison, venus justement en personne présenter ce fameux
phonographe, à l'exposition
universelle de 1889.
Alors, Gustave Eiffel
y passe des heures, à étudier les moyens
qui pourraient sauver sa tour.
Il commence par faire installer un pendule
de Foucault sous le deuxième étage.
Les oscillations amplifiées vont mettre
en évidence la rotation de la Terre.
Mais il le sait, ça ne suffira pas
à convaincre les autorités.
Cette expérience a déjà été réalisée au Panthéon, quelques années auparavant.
Il mise plutôt sur une science
encore balbutiante : la météorologie.
À 300 mètres d'altitude, le vent,
la température, l'hygrométrie,
c'est-à-dire le taux d'humidité dans l'air,
ne sont pas les mêmes qu'au sol.
Ces mesures sont cruciales
pour comprendre le temps qu'il fait
et réaliser des prévisions.
Avec l'aide du physicien
Éleuthère Mascart,
Eiffel installe au cinquième étage,
une station météo unique au monde.
Les instruments sont disposés
sur une petite plateforme
et toutes les heures,
ils mesurent la température de l'air,
la vitesse du vent,
la pression, l'hygrométrie.
Les données sont aussitôt transmises
par câble à des appareils enregistreurs
situés au sol.
Les résultats sont ensuite publiés
aux frais de Gustave Eiffel, lui-même.
Finalement, c'est grâce à cette station
que l'on connaît avec précision
le temps qu'il fait à Paris
depuis la fin du XIXè siècle.
Evidemment, depuis,
les appareils ont beaucoup évolués.
Merci m'sieurs, dames !
Ouf, ça souffle !
À cette altitude, il y a toujours du vent.
Un phénomène auquel Gustave
Eiffel s'intéresse tout particulièrement,
surtout depuis qu'en 1884,
un viaduc s'est effondré
à cause d'une tempête.
Pour mesurer ses effets
sur les structures,
il fait installer un dispositif astucieux
au deuxième étage
pour mesurer la pression
que le vent exerce sur les objets.
Je vous explique, mais avant, on descend.
À l'ouverture,
en 1889, les visiteurs peuvent déjà monter
et descendre grâce à 5 ascenseurs,
parmi lesquels 3 sont hydrauliques.
Aujourd'hui, 2 fonctionnent encore.
Eiffel fait pendre un câble de 115 mètres
entre ce deuxième étage
et le plancher des vaches.
Il avait baptisé ce dispositif :
“l'appareil de chute”.
Sur ce câble, les scientifiques
font glisser des objets de tailles
et de formes différentes.
Un système de mesures fixé
aux objets, eux-mêmes, permettait
d'évaluer la résistance de l'air aux corps
en chute libre, et inversement,
la pression que l'air en mouvement exerce
sur les corps immobiles.
Plus tard, Eiffel complète
ses expériences sur l'air
et le vent en installant
un laboratoire d'aérodynamique.
Il se trouvait
au pied de la Tour, avant d'être déplacé
dans le 16ème arrondissement en 1912.
Finalement,
c'est une autre invention révolutionnaire
qui va sauver
la Dame de fer : la télégraphie sans fil.
C'est une technique
qui utilise les ondes électromagnétiques
pour transmettre des messages
en alphabet morse.
Le 5 novembre 1898,
Gustave Eiffel autorise l'industriel Eugène Ducretet à réaliser, depuis
la Tour, la toute première
transmission sans fil française.
Le premier message est envoyé au Panthéon qui se trouve à 4 kilomètres.
Les ondes électromagnétiques
parcourent cette distance
sans rencontrer le moindre obstacle.
Le principe de la radio est né.
Un poste émetteur est alors installé à demeure.
Il permet en 1899
d'établir une liaison avec Londres.
Peu après, en 1903,
le capitaine Gustave Ferrié,
qui est chargé par l'armée d'étudier
les applications militaires de la TSF,
saute sur l'occasion et propose d'y
installer ses antennes au cinquième étage.
Grâce à ses antennes radio,
la Tour joue désormais
un rôle stratégique de premier plan
pour le pays.
Elle devient incontournable.
Je dirais même plus,
elle devient indéboulonnable !
Et, le 1er mai 1910,
la ville de Paris renouvelle
sa concession pour 70 ans.
Gustave Eiffel a gagné son pari.
Et l'histoire ne s'arrête pas là !
À la même époque,
la radio commence à pénétrer
dans les foyers et le 22 décembre 1921,
c'est la naissance de "Radio Tour Eiffel",
qui remporte un immense succès.
La station émettra pendant 19 ans jusqu'à
l'occupation allemande en juin 1940.
Plus tard, la Dame de fer deviendra
le berceau de la télévision française.
Le tout premier émetteur
est installé au sommet en 1935,
mais ça Gustave Eiffel ne le verra pas.
Il s'éteint le 27 décembre 1923.
Aujourd'hui, grâce à toutes ces antennes,
elle a grandi.
En mars 2022, elle a atteint
330 mètres.
Alors la tour Eiffel n'est
plus le plus haut bâtiment de la planète,
mais son seul nom évoque le prestige
de notre capitale dans le monde entier.
Ce n'était donc pas par hasard si,
chaque année, plus de 6 millions
de personnes des 4 coins du monde
viennent la visiter.
La tour de Gustave Eiffel est désormais
l'un des monuments payants
les plus visités au monde.
Et voilà, fin de la visite.
Alors si cette balade épicurieuse sur la tour Eiffel vous a plu, je vous conseille
vivement de venir la découvrir
ou la re-découvrir par vous-même.
Les plus sportifs pourront même gravir les marches qui mènent au deuxième étage.
Vous verrez, c'est
une expérience inoubliable pour les yeux
et pour les mollets.
Allez, excellente semaine
à toutes et à tous et à dimanche prochain.